what lessons what are the biggest
lessons you take away from World War One
maybe we talked about several but you
know you look back at the 20th century
what
as a historian
what do you learn about human nature
about human civilization
bought history
from looking at this War
I think the
the lesson I
would want everyone to take from the
story of the first World War uh is that
human life is not cheap
that all of the warring Powers thought
that just by throwing
more men and more material at the front
they would solve their political
problems with military force and
at the end of the day in 1918 one side
did win that but it didn't actually
solve any of those political problems
and in the end
the regular people
paid the price of their lives they did
and people who
people who had been told that their
lives were cheap
uh remembered that right and it sort of
you know reshapes Mass politics for the
rest of the 20th century both in Europe
and around the world
yeah the
yeah the cost of a death of a single
soldier is not just or a single civilian
is not just the cost of that single life
it's the resentment
that the anger the hate the reverberates
throughout one of the things I saw in
Ukraine is the birth of
at scale of generational hate not
towards administrations or leaders but
towards entire peoples
and that hey I mean overnight that hate
is created and it takes perhaps decades
for that hate to dissipate
it takes decades and it takes uh it
takes Collective effort to build
institutions that divert that that hate
into into other places
one of the biggest
things I thought was not part of the
calculus and when the United States
invaded Afghanistan and Iraq
is the creation of hate when you when
you drop a bomb
um even if it hits military targets even
if he kills
soldiers which in that case
it didn't there's a very large amount of
civilians
what does that do to the yeah like
um how many years minutes hours months
and years of hate to create with a
single bomb you you drop and like
calculate that like literally
and the Pentagon have a chart how many
people will hate us uh how many people
does it take do some signs here how many
people does it take when you have a
million people that hate you how many of
them will become terrorists
uh how many of them
uh will do something to the nation you
love and care about which is the United
States will do something that will be
very costly
I feel like there was not a plot in a
chart it was more about short-term
effects
uh yes it's again it's the idea of using
uh military force to solve political
problems um and I think there's a
squandering of of Goodwill that people
have around the world towards the United
States
um you know that's a respect for uh you
know for its economy for its consumer
products and so forth and I think that's
um uh that's been lost a lot of that do
you think leaders can stop War
I have uh perhaps a romantic notion
perhaps because I do these podcasts in
person and so on that leaders that get
in a room together and can talk
they can stop War I mean that's the
power of a leader especially one with a
uh in an authoritarian regime
that they can through camaraderie
alleviate some of the emotions
associated with the ego
yes leaders can stop War if they get
into the room
when they understand
um from
the masses in their countries that were
something that they want stopped
and so the people ultimately have a
really big say they do you know that it
was the it was mass movements by people
in the United States for the nuclear
freeze um in Russia pushing for for
openness that brought for example
um Ronald Reagan and Mikhail Gorbachev
to Reykjavik to sort of debate uh you
know uh and eventually sort of put caps
on on nuclear weapons
um you know those two people did you
know made choices in the room that made
that possible
um but they were both being pushed
um uh and knew they were being pushed by
by their people
boy that's a tough one it puts a lot of
responsibility on the German people for
example
in both Wars
we fans of History tend to conceive of
history as a meeting of leaders we think
of Chamberlain we think of Churchill and
the importance of them in the Second
World War I think about Hitler and
Stalin and think that if certain
conversations happen they could have the
war could have been avoided you tell the
story of how many times Hitler
and Nazi Germany's military might
was not sufficient they could have been
easily stopped
and uh the pacifists
the people who believed Hitler were
foolish enough to believe Hitler didn't
act properly and if the leaders just
woke up to that idea
in fact
um
a church was a kind of representation of
that but in your conception here it's
possible that Churchill was also a
representation of the British people
even though seemingly unpopular
he that force was
um
they gave birth to somebody like
Churchill who said we'll never surrender
right yes she'll fight in the beaches
yeah and that you know it's a I think uh
World War II Britain is a good example
of that you know it's uh it is clearly a
you know a dynamic leader who has his
pulse on what the people uh want and
demand and are willing to do
um and you know it's a it's a dynamic
art of of leading that uh and shaping
those wants at the same time as as
knowing that you're you're bound by them